budget déficitaire près de 53 milliards
de dollars prévue pour 2022 23 mai une
amélioration majeure de la situation
financière en raison de l'inflation des
prix du pétrole de la croissance
économique ces 50 milliards de dollars
de mieux que prévu sur le plan
budgétaire depuis la mise à jour
économique du mois de décembre ce qui
permet donc au gouvernement de financer
ses priorités est de voir la dette
baissé plus rapidement que prévu aussi
par rapport au pib la priorité des
priorités c'est l'immobilier création du
compte d'épargné libre d'impôt à l'achat
d'une première propriété
vous pourrez placer 8000 $ par année
dans un celi pour l'achat d'une première
propriété
déductibles d'impôts comme un reér et
avec des retraits non imposables comme
un celi jusqu'à 40000 dollars pour
utilisation une fois dans sa vie et si
vous ne l'utilisez pas vous pouvez
transférer cet argent dans votre reér on
bonifie également le crédit sur l'achat
d'une première propriété on ajoute un
crédit rénovation de 7500 $ sur les
maisons multigénérationnel également et
le gouvernement prévoit 4 milliards sur
cinq ans pour construire cent mille
logements et on va taxer ce qu'on
appelle les flip les revend précipité à
l'intérieur de 12 mois une imposition
complète sur les bénéfices réalisés à
titre de revenu d'entreprise donc c'est
c'est vraiment la grosse partie du
budget mais il ya d'autres choses quand
même on va instaurer un nouveau
programme de soins dentaires gratuits
pour les moins de 12 ans cette année
pour les moins de 18 ans à partir de
l'an prochain
les aînés également sont visés les
personnes en situation de handicap alors
les ménages pour avoir droit ceux ci
soins dentaires gratuits doivent avoir
un revenu annuel inférieur à 90 milles
dollars par année à noter aussi
qu'ottawa va élargir son un statut de
5000 $ sur les véhicules électriques aux
fourgonnettes aux camions et vv us
également et ottawa va créer aussi un
crédit sur les investissements dans le
captage et le stockage de carbone on
annonce une rose l'impôt pour les
banques et pour les compagnies
d'assurances mais il ya davantage de pme
qui auront accès aux taux d'imposition
de 9% plutôt que 15 % et dernière chose
le gouvernement crée
fond de croissance de 15 milliards pour
la transition climatique est une
stratégie également pour les minéraux
critique c'est un gros budget
pourrait-on dire mais toujours pas de
cible de retour à l'équilibré budgétaire